there have been three big changes in the
family in the last generation first the
definition of the family has changed so
we now have adoptive families blended
families nuclear families living in
separate houses and divorced families
living in the same house also we have
women have flooded into the workplace
two-thirds of women now work outside of
the home and the last thing which we
don't talk about as much is that men
have come flooding into the parenting
space and dads are much more involved in
families and I think this new generation
of parents because they are much more
active and much busier technology work
etc they're much more interested in
solution so that the old debates be
strict like the Chinese or Beale acts
like the French are no longer satisfying
for them they want results they want to
know what works and they want to be able
to do it in their families I'm the
father of identical twin girls and my
wife works and we were incredibly
chaotic we just felt lost and out of
control we would turn to our parents but
their experience was so outdated as to
be almost quaint we'd Facebook our
friends but they're just as clueless as
we are and then we went looking for
results and the traditional solutions
just seemed very tired and out-of-date
and yet at the same time that these
family experts were telling us the same
thing over and over again in every other
area of contemporary life from business
to sports to the military there's all
these new ideas about how to make teams
and groups work more effectively and so
I want to go out find out what those
folks were doing in their homes and then
test those ideas out with my own wife
and kids and my wife put one red line in
the sand she said okay I'm willing to
try new things I'm desperate but I don't
want fury I don't want some academic
telling me what to do I want to know
that real families were actually doing
these real things that I'm willing to
try there is this idea about families
that exists no place else we have our
jobs we work on those we have our copies
we work on those we have our bodies our
relationships we work on those somehow
there's this idea that that families are
just supposed to be it's supposed to be
organic that kids come with their own
instruction manuals
but every parent I know doesn't feel
that way we feel like our lives are out
of control and if I could put it in one
headline I would say that as a parent I
felt like I was always playing defense
and never playing offense and yet
there's all these new ideas out there so
if that's where the action is if the
action is in business or in sports or in
someplace else let's bring those ideas
in if your family doesn't have this
problem fine don't take these solutions
I'm surely not wagging my finger and
telling people what to do I'm saying
that we were desperate for new ideas
iwent founding them and I found a way
out of them in unlikely places when I
set out working on the secrets of happy
families I made a vow to myself that I
wouldn't squeeze everything into a list
of three or five or seven things that
you must do to have a happy family I
love you but I hate those lists I forget
number two I disagree with number four
and I feel like I'm doomed one things I
tried to do was to put 200 new ideas in
this book because it would be very
obvious that nobody could do them all
but if you pick three or five or seven
that works for you and it might be
different than what works for me or what
works for my sister I think you can have
a happier family and to me the biggest
takeaway is you don't need some master
plan you don't need some big new scheme
that's gonna be hard to set up and
impossible to follow you should take
small steps and accumulate small wins
what's the secret for the happy family
you